just before I get started the slides for
this talk are on my website right now
I'm telling you this because there's a
ton of content and we have a short
period of time here so I'm gonna cram
through it and you will want to review
later so now you know where to find it I
have a book in my bag and on that book I
draw all sorts of layouts all the time
that's how I design websites they start
with a piece of paper and I'll just draw
some stuff and I go haha this would be
super cool so a couple of years ago I
made this design and when you look at it
you go yeah this looks like a standard
web design it's fairly basic it has some
interesting stuff like there's the
categories and title at the top and then
you have the featured image and then you
have the meta content on the left hand
side or right hand side right hand side
and then the content itself and you go
yeah sure this is relatively easy to do
except on smaller screens I wanted to
make a slight change move the meta
content from next to the content up
above the featured image and then on
even smaller screens I want to move the
featured image of above rest of the
content and at this point you go this is
not so easy you see any one of these
three on their own as a piece of cake
combined on one website with just CSS
and HTML impossible because you'd have
to change the markup structure to get
this to work with old layout tools so
instead you'd have to go with JavaScript
and have to change everything which is
not great because then you're changing
everything and it shouldn't be like that
today I want to talk to you about a
whole new way of thinking about layouts
on the web and this whole new way of
thinking about layouts will truly change
the way we design websites from here on
forward I'm not talking about emerging
technologies that are coming two or
three years from now I'm talking about
technologies that are here today that
you
to start using today it's called CSS
grid I'm Morten Ramm Hendrickson and
let's get cracking so just to prove to
you that I'm not making things up this
is the layout I drew built purely in
HTML and CSS and WordPress running in a
browser today and all the stuff that you
saw is happening plus a bunch of other
things this website you're seeing here
is my website so if you go to Morton com
grab the side of your browser and start
doing this you'll actually see the
content jumping around on the page and
your brain will say there's some
JavaScript happening here or this might
be bootstrap it's not it's just pure
simple CSS and in fact the HTML behind
it is cleaner than any HTML you'll ever
see from WordPress before this point so
instead of going through the entire
WordPress theme which will take way too
long I decided to make a slightly
simpler example so I made this little
web page for the room we're in so this
is the speaker track for today and when
you look at it I want you to think about
how you would make this layout using
only HTML and CSS no frameworks nothing
else just look at it for one second I
think how would I mark this up all right
it's here so first you're probably going
to do something like draw boxes around
the main items so here we have some sort
of header thing and then there's a huge
section on the side but all the content
and then on the other side there's like
a logo and then there's some other
sidebar stuff good so we have those
boxes and we'll mark that up in HTML
then because we have to lay this out we
need to start grouping elements so below
the main header thing there's a bunch of
content but the content is displayed in
two columns so we need to put a box
around them so we can float them left to
right or use flex to put them left and
right then in the sidebar we have
another grouping of contents and since
we're floating that we need to put a box
around that and then inside the cyber
itself there's two more pieces of
content that need box to surround them
so we end up with something like this
the blue sections are semantic markup
things that are required for the
document to work this is the actual
content the red sections are boxes that
we drew around content solely to say
this is a thing that will go next to
another thing and this is another thing
that will go next to another thing and
you can see that the mark-up is full of
that stuff when you start looking at
responsively as that gets super
complicated because in this responsive
layout you see that that thing the black
box that's on the sidebar that's
actually the header and this the small
box on the far right hand side that has
some address information that's actually
the footer and on a mobile display the
semantic structure is as it should be on
the other end of the scale everything
has been moved around and then you say I
can do this
bootstrap is my friend everything is
fine the problem is what bootstrap does
to fix this and all the other frameworks
is take the HTML and apply some
JavaScript and move the HTML around in
the document to get this stuff to work
that means for accessibility reasons the
whole document is now jumbled which is
not great it also means we're leaning on
external technologies just to do
something that should work on its own
the problem is web layouts the way we've
been doing it since the beginning of web
time have always been broken and all
we've been doing this entire time is
refine how we break the layout so we
started with tables then we had frames
then we had layers then we had floats
and clears then we had flexbox and all
this stuff is trying to solve this
fundamental problem which is a web
document so HTML is a document that
starts at the top and ends at the bottom
and anytime you want to put something
next to something else you have to
somehow break the document just to do
that which goes against everything we
want to do in design consider this super
simple example you have a box
and then two boxes inside two column
layout simple right should be well if
you look at just the markup this is what
you get just two boxes below each other
with a box around them then you have to
put them next to one another so you use
float few floats one item to the left
and the other one item to the right and
then the box that surrounds the
collapses because of course you're
floating content so you're pulling them
out of the structure of the document and
then you want content to float around it
to fix that you then have to introduce a
clear fix so that's just empty content
that you stuff from the bottom corner
solely for the purpose of making that
box wrap around the contents again and
then you say well we have better tools
now we have flex box and it's true flex
box does solve this problem but if I
make it just one element more
complicated flex box doesn't help us
anymore because now we can't say to flex
put the content to other pieces next to
another than one piece not flex box
would try to treat all three as the same
thing because flex box works in one
direction either horizontal or vertical
so now we have to introduce an extra box
and say can you please flex this
container thing next to the other thing
and then inside the container we'll put
two things underneath one another this
is the hack this is not the way it's
supposed to be this is truly a hack this
is how we design websites today we cheat
we build a bunch of extra stuff just to
get our layouts to work it's nuts if you
think about it it's totally crazy flawed
and flex
forced us to put extra content into our
HTML for the sole purpose of layouts
which goes against everything we've
learned about how to markup websites
this is also layouts today this is how
we have to do things well it is today
that you're gonna change all this just
before I get into it consider what the
web looks like right now
this is bootstrap the official
documentation telling you how to make a
layout that has two columns look at the
HTML look
how many nested divs are necessary to
get this to work
this is WordPress theme builder plus
some sort of page layouts plugin I can
tell you by looking at this HTML all of
this stuff generates a box with some
content in it but it's necessary because
we have to do all this floating and
clearing and nesting and nesting and
nesting and nesting underscores that's
the same in a slightly less extreme
version when you look at the overall
markup of underscores there's a bunch of
elements within underscores that are
there solely for the purpose of layout
so the blue boxes here are the header
the main the side and the footer the red
boxes are there for layout purposes so
what if we could take all that extra
craft away have just the semantic markup
and nothing else and then solve the
layout problems in CSS in a clean and
simple way instead of this layout we'd
have this which is easier to read it
makes way more sense what if we didn't
have to do all this crazy stuff anymore
if you look at my example the blue items
are the ones that matter the red don't
but even if I take away the red items
the structure of this document still
makes no sense we have a heading 1 then
we have a main then we have a header
then we have an aside and then we have a
footer if I take all the extra craft
away and reorganize the document all of
a sudden it makes much more sense from a
semantic standpoint header h1 main aside
footer the problem is up until this
point all our layout tools have been
content out and one-dimensional meaning
you apply a layout to an individual item
and then you have to relate that item to
other things what we need is a to demand
a layout that works layout in and that's
what CSS grid gives us so instead of
doing all the boxing thing I was talking
about before what if we start by saying
here's what we want let's apply a grid
to it just like you would do in design
you draw a grid on top and then you say
we're gonna place contents on this grid
so you have your semantic markup then
you simply grab each item the header the
h1 the main the side buyer and the
footer and you place them on the
document that makes sense all of a
sudden you know the thing with the guy
with the blinds that everyone shares on
the internet all the time
that's it'll be like zip old applies
work too bad this works perfectly go to
code pen this example is a live website
all those screen grabs are from the
website all the content restructures the
way it's supposed to you can play around
with it you can see exactly what's going
on and the craziest part is when you
read the code you'll be like I
understand what's happening here I don't
even need to understand CSS grid I can
actually see how this works so how does
it work
I've been told that listening to my
talks could be a bit like trying to
capture a firehose sometimes so I've
decided to try to structure this in such
a way that it's more like strapping fire
hoses on a platform and then flying all
right but but this means I need your
absolute attention I'm gonna crash
through some stuff here if it'll be nice
and quick okay so brace yourself stand
firm CSS grid needs new terminology so
we have grid container grade item grid
line grid cell good track grid area grid
gap I apologize I know you have to do
this there's a simultaneous translator
you're just not appreciate me speaking
fast
so a grid container is any container in
your document now you create a grid
inside you do that by simply declaring
display grid you can do this to as many
elements as you want on the page it just
in that it does not matter a grid item
is any direct descendant of a grid
container so if you create a grid any
direct descendant automatically becomes
a grid item that's placed inside the
grid but only the first level
descendants just like it is with flexbox
a grid line is any of the lines you draw
inside the grid horizontal or vertical
the grid lines are numbered by default
so the first edge of the grid either
vertical horizontal has to line number
one and then you just count them two
three four five six and the last one has
the last number a grid cell is any cell
inside the grid a grid area is any
defined rectangular area and inside the
grid that covers more than one cell a
grid track is either a horizontal track
or a vertical tracks or a row or a
column and a great gap is the space
between each of the cells if you choose
to add basically gutters got that good
don't worry these slides are online you
can go look at them later and this will
become part of your vocabulary anyway so
CSS grid in a nutshell how does this
actually work how do we apply it today
number one define a grid on an element
where you want a grid to appear number
two place items within that grid where
you want them to appear
number three make world peace that's all
there is to it
what does it look like well here's my
example this is the semantic markup with
know CSS apply except for color then we
start by grabbing just the site
container that's the container that
wraps everything and we declare display
grid so now we have a grid then we
decide how many columns and how many
rows we want I mean you do that using
grid template columns and grid template
rows and here what we do is say the
distance from the
edge of the grid to the first line
that's the first Valley then the
distance to the next one it's the next
value and so on and so on
so you're declaring the width between
each of the lines and then another line
is drawn this comes with new features
like the fr or fraction value that
allows you to say take one fraction of
the available space and then put a line
there so you can make truly dynamic
layout do the same with rows you just
declare a list where you want the rows
appear and they will appear
automatically once you've drawn lower
rows you have cells and your browser
automatically places all the direct
descendants of the grid element in those
cells from the top left to the bottom
right then for each individual element
you can if you want to declare a grid
column and a grid row property and say I
want this element to appear from column
line 2 to column line 4 and from row
line 2 to row line 3 that means you
literally find column line 2 and column
line 4 and you put the content in
between those two lines
same with rows well I here you see what
I'm talking about we're doing layout in
so we create the layout first let me
just dump content where we want them to
appear when you look at this you realize
there are all these new things you can
do like for instance create actual white
space on a layout you can just choose
not to populate cells then you have
white space no space urges or anything
like that anymore
once you know this you can then place
any of your elements anywhere you want
some the grid looks promising right but
uh you have to do all this counting
stuff I keep track of the line numbers
and then what if it's responsibly to
keep changing the greater gets kind of
nuts in my layout I move elements
particularly the header on the footer
keeping track alive with numbers would
be a pain and
to be fair you can't actually give each
of the track lines a name and refer to
them by name instead of my number but
that's still quite a lot of stuff to
deal with so we have this new property
called grid template areas and grid
template areas is nuts it's almost like
a ski you declare grid template area and
then you write out each of the cells and
your grid and you say what is the name
of this cell so for instance here I have
the three cells at the top our title
title title and then we have main header
header and main slide bar footer then
you use the grid area property on
individual child items and you just
declare the name of the area you want
that woman to appear so if you say grid
area header well that's wrong no it's
right if you say grid area header the
element goes to the header area if you
say grid area title it goes to the title
area and this allows us to do crazy
responsive web design because that means
instead of doing a bunch of crazy stuff
all you have to do is change the grid
template areas and then the items that
you've already said this is going in the
title area this is going in the header
area we'll just move around the grid so
your responsive code and your media
queries become very very simple and
anyone who reads this code can see okay
so we have a grid that has two columns
and then we put the title and title and
mine and header and main and sidebar and
then when the screen gets wider we have
three columns and here we have title
title title main header header the CSS
actually visibly declares what's going
on no more no more everything just works
this is the point where your brain will
start going like this doesn't actually
compute yet
and trust me I've been working with this
for over a year every time I sit down
and do a new grid layout my brain keeps
telling me to do things the old way and
I have to keep throwing my brain out and
then replacing it with a new one
which means my kid is walking around in
the background they're making noises
when he grows up he won't think the way
I do and he'll be like this is super
simple and then I'll tell them about
flows and clear why would you do it like
that that's so crazy there's also this
weird little thing called nested grids
now in the original grid specification
from a couple of years ago you had the
ability to create a grid and then have
an element within the grid inherit the
grid so you would get consistency that
never happened in browsers so instead
what we do is we declare multiple grids
inside one another and it turns out
that's actually a huge benefit because
then you can say I have an overall
layout grid right layout my header my
footer my sidebar and so on then you can
have a sub grid just for the main
content layout and you can even have a
grid inside that read before something
else and you have detailed control over
every single component within your
layout and as you know the new trend in
web design is to work on component level
well let's the grids allow you to
literally work on component level and
this means for example if you're making
a wordpress theme you can make
individual content grids for individual
types of content so if you apply a
certain class to any element then you
can change the grid completely using
pure CSS no more fancy templates and
crazy PHP just use CSS but older
browsers this is the absolute biggest
argument against CSS grid first of all
all modern browsers support CSS grid now
every single one of them there's an
issue but I'll get to that in a second
before we get to that there's also the
question of I think it's too soon this
is emerging technology it's not mature
yet
true it's emerging technology but you
know small websites like the New York
Times have started using them so I would
say any client that says we're not ready
for this yet because no one is using it
is can be urged forward this is
something we can do today but there are
two elephants in the room right so you
have these see you give me way too much
credit
they're always these things that don't
work the way we want to so we have an
Internet Explorer 10 and 11 and we have
edge who are not currently following the
spec exactly point of order if it wasn't
for Internet Explorer 10 we wouldn't
have CSS grid CSS grid was invented for
Internet Explorer 10 and the reason why
these two browsers are lagging behind is
because the other browsers decided to
change the spec but the spec is built
into Windows so Microsoft has to update
all of their operating systems to get
this to catch on however edge is
probably a couple of weeks away from
getting full grid support and I'll show
you how to create proper backwards
compatibility for all other browsers
there's this other thing that has
nothing to do with CSS grid that's
called a feature query that we can use
now to ask a browser do you support this
grid problem this CSS property and we
can use that to test whether or not the
browser supports grid the canonical best
practice is to ask add support display
grid works exactly like a media query so
if it says yes then we run the code
inside the problem is edge does support
grid it just sports the wrong spec so if
you're testing for grid support and edge
test for something that edge does not
support within the grid spec for example
grid area auto then edge won't try to
run the grid my recommendation here is
actually to serve up the mobile
experience on all browsers that don't
support grid
and this is where people fall off the
horse right this is like wait wait wait
wait what so that means the site will
look the same in all browsers that's
exactly right
the thing is we've been doing responsive
web design for ten years now no we have
not we've been doing responsive web
design since 2010 and that we've
established an entire language around
not serving up the same experience
across all browsers because on a mobile
browser the website looks totally
different from what it does on a large
desktop browser there is no actual
reason why a website should look the
same across all browsers except that we
keep saying they should so we can change
our methodology around this making
everything look the same across all
browsers is a bad habit we should be
making things look the best they can on
whatever browsers are supported in
responsive web design allows us to do
this we just had to migrate it from not
just saying responsive web design it's
about the width of the screen to also
say we can make it responsive to the age
of the browser accessible mobile first
layouts work well on all browsers if you
don't believe me go look at the mobile
version of Wikipedia on your desktop
browser you will never use regular
Wikipedia again the mobile version on
the desktop browser is so much better I
don't understand why they just don't
move forward this is progressive
enhancement this is our responsibility
we progressively enhance the web because
if we don't then we'll get stuck in the
past forever so practical approach to
CSS grid right now so you can use it
when you walk out of this room first
build accessible mobile first layouts
without grid that is your baseline so
make it work on a mobile phone make it
sure that it still works when it's on a
wide screen then use that mobile first
layout as the fallback so if everything
goes to hell
mobile-first works then use add support
to detect grid support at the
appropriate break point when everything
starts looking weird add a grid then
keep scaling up the width of the screen
add another grid add another grid on
another grid because people have screens
that are this wide right now so you need
to account for that if you don't believe
me go to my brother's house he has two
ridiculously here screen
so remember the layout I drew that was
impossible if you apply grid to it it's
not only impossible it's something that
makes sense and just works and it's the
layout that send a new theme on my
website and you can go check it out on
github and put it on your own site as
well your path to CSS grid starts here
today right now number one use Firefox
when you develop because Firefox has a
grid inspector so anytime you find it an
element that has grid on it there's a
little hashtag type thing that's
supposed to look like your grid and if
you click on that in the inspector the
gridlines appear in your browser and you
can actually see the grid while you're
working with it I'm sure the other
browsers will catch up and right now
Firefox has it
second Rachel andrew has a website
called grid by example this is basically
doctrine rachel andrew is by and large
the reason why we have CSS cribben
browsers today she's been pushing it for
years and years and years and she's
documented absolutely everything so we
want to know how it works go to grid by
example Mozilla developer Network has
tons of documentation most of it written
by either Rachel Andrew or gem Simmons
it is a great resource it's documented
every single property and everything
that's going on CSS tricks has a
complete guide to CSS grid which is just
like the complete guide to flexbox which
is also the same content over again [ __ ]
my new theme which is running on my
website is on github and you can go
check it out pick it apart
send pull requests complain about the
lack of internationalization what you'll
notice is CSS grid respects text
direction so there is no RTL see a style
sheet because wood CSS grid you don't
need it anymore
I wrote an article about this that came
out in Smashing Magazine yesterday
called the building production-ready CSS
grid layout today that covers what I
talked about here plus how I designed
the theme plus a bunch of other stuff go
read it go where you want to go where
you want the web to go and the rest will
follow we in this room control a large
percentage of the web and if we all
adopt CSS for it now and do it properly
the web will follow don't believe me
this is the LinkedIn office in
Carpinteria that I go to occasionally
they built a new building and then they
put this huge patch of grass directly in
front of the entrance so if you look at
the image here there's a building here
so everyone walks like this and I saw
the patch of grass so this was taken on
the first day and I'm like this is
insane
whoever designed this was now thinking
about the end user so I just started
walking across the grass and I was
walking across the grass for a couple
hours to make a path and then a couple
of months later someone sent me this
picture and then their code a week ago
someone sent me this picture
if you paved cow paths meaning walk
where you want everything to head
eventually someone put paving stones
down so designers in the room
CSS grid means you can finally use
proper grid systems in your designs
there also means design the browser is
now really easy theme developers start
using CSS grid today in all your work
even if it means providing full
fallbacks for everything you do I have
links for that if you want to talk to me
later
framework people CSS grid cures your
dividers so you should take a strong
inoculation right now page builders this
is make or break time
CSS grid plus Guttenberg and WordPress
means that most of what page builders
does will be handled inside WordPress
itself so if you're building a page
builder you need to get on top of the
spec and figure out how it fits into
your business model set best practices
be responsible because CSS grid allows
you to mess around with the structure
order of your content and can make sites
really inaccessible so don't do that but
use it for good build the web you want
to see and repeat after me
make it accessible make it fancy and
make sure the fancy doesn't break
accessibility oh come on
stand up everyone of you stand up come
on everyone of you stand up this is your
mantra all right number one what
number two number three thank you very
much
awesome okay winner take five minutes of
questions now do we have questions in
the room because I guess the alternative
is everyone piles on Morten and an
expert bar or somewhere like that where
do you think you're going to be for
questions if people want to come in and
get into the detail expert Baron
Haussmann right okay Oh what you are
gonna have to ask questions the other
room is running late they're not as
sharp as we are so I need some questions
on the floor while you're thinking about
that I have got a question to get
started with hmm what really is the
guttenberg implications with CSS grid
can you think of some really nice
examples straight off the bat okay so
are you all familiar with Gutenberg the
new content editor yeah okay so there's
a new content editor coming to WordPress
called Gutenberg that works on the
principle of block elements so instead
of saying you're right a bunch of
content and you add an image and they
write a bunch of content and there's
just one big blob you're now able to say
add block that is a quote add a block
that is regular text add a block that is
something else at a block that is a
video add a block that is and inline
something and the idea over time is that
Gutenberg will evolve to have things
like columns and things like other types
of layouts which is completely new to us
in the WordPress community if you take
that idea that all the stuff that you
put into a blog post or eventually all
the stuff you put on the entire view
because Gutenberg will likely evolved to
the point where you can customize the
entire view including your header and
your sidebar and everything else and
then combine that with CSS grid there's
a door that opens to customization
within WordPress that is truly mind
breaking which is imagine if you go into
the content editor WordPress in you're
writing up posts or some other type of
content and then you say for this
content I want to have an extra sidebar
and then you can go in and just
out a guide and place content to the
left or the right of that guy I'm not
saying that this is what the Guttenberg
team is working on now I'm sure if
anyone in the rooms from the good work
team they're like this is not part of it
I haven't written this article yet I
have crazy ideas but the thing is once
we have CSS grid all the layout
components of a layout are handled by
the CSS and that means you can provide
different style style rules for
individual types of content on the page
and it also means that WordPress can
generate different layouts in pure CSS
because Guttenberg outputs everything at
block levels so you can target each
individual block that's added to the
content as a grid item so this opens the
door for WordPress itself to become a
page builder it also opens the door for
WordPress itself to allow for custom
layouts for each individual piece of
content to create across a WordPress
site
this could happen it should happen it
should also be in the hands of theme
developers to control how much of this
customization is possible but this is
one of those times
when all paths are open and whatever we
do besides where we end up going yes
yeah that was long ago yet okay thank
you kind of mind-blowing very cool that
come on there must be some questions
yeah yes so do note your hop to the
microphone ground a big wall story if
you could do that there's another mic
from the others as well but gram your
question please yes thanks Morton there
is unbelievably informative presentation
you mentioned flexbox earlier do you
think that with the use of grids that
it's going to effectively replace the
necessity for flex box or is could you
see the two coexisting in any situations
will CSS flex CSS and flex box coexist
absolutely CSS grid and flex
coexistence allows us to do magical
things they should be used in
conjunction with each other in fact grid
flex and float all have a place in
layouts is just now we can use float for
what it supposed to be which is floating
elements next to other elements and
letting content flow around it we can
use flex for what it's supposed to be
which is flexing contents within a box
to either line up horizontally or
vertically or break nicely and then we
can use grid for the overall layout so
one of the most interesting demos I've
seen of CSS grid so far was a grid where
they used they made an actual grid and
they put content inside each of the
cells and then they use flex to scale
the contents in each of the cells to be
consistent so using grid and flex
together mates for that gives us extra
layout tools that we previously didn't
have because we can now relegate the
responsibility to the right type of tool
fine set was a great answer cheese okay
yes again me tree hi Morten thanks for
the great talk and my question is I know
that the future of the web is kind of
influenced by what the default WordPress
themes do in terms of layouts in terms
of CSS in terms of HTML do you have a
strategy to like advocate CSS grids to
use them in default themes and how we as
theme developers can influence that and
what are like step-by-step guide to use
more you CSS graze more okay there are
two questions there so first is there a
strategy in place to make the default
theme in WordPress use CSS grid yes I am
building a conspiracy to make that
happen
I started it last year so
there but but seriously there are
conversations around this because
hopefully the next considering the
introduction of Gutenberg the next
WordPress team should display what it's
possible and as far as I'm concerned
what is possible becomes more
interesting if we use CSS grid for it of
course
when we when WordPress ships a default
theme you have to consider the fact that
WordPress is a global tool that people
use all over the world and we have to
account for every single type of user
including users that are on older
hardware on slower networks on less
updated browsers so in that conversation
we have to have a conversation about
backwards compatibility about how to
handle fall backs properly and all that
kind of stuff and my scorched-earth
policy on responsive on progressive
enhancement might not work for WordPress
core but I think we're going to get
there as for everyone else who is not
developing a core theme that ships with
WordPress you should use CSS grid in
your layouts even if it's just a
progressive enhancement for modern
browsers because a year from now two
years from now five years from now this
is what's going to be expected and you
need to learn it now because otherwise
the kids that are in school now who are
learning web design who are learning
this stuff will just jump over you case
this is better and easier and more
performance thank you thank you
anyone else any more from the floor I
think you got AB under the expert bar
that'll be good okay
oh yes yes sir so for those of us who
like to learn by breaking things
is there a CSS grid theme you'd
recommend we start off with so as far as
I know based on doing no research
I think the kunda theme I built is
probably the first WordPress theme that
only uses CSS code for layouts I don't
know if there are other things that do
it by all means go trash it it's on
github and it's even on my website so
you can just muck around with it on the
website I'm going to document that theme
once it's done it's still in its infancy
and but I'd like to see more themes
showing up the thing with CSS grid is
all the things that we know about
layouts are no longer relevant
this requires a completely different way
of thinking about web layouts and if you
approach it that way so you just start
designing something without considering
you know floats and clears and
everything then you can do new
interesting things and I would love to
see our community start building new and
interesting designs using CSS grid
layout that break the norms you'll
notice that [ __ ] pretty much sticks
within common parameters about design
because I want it to be something that
people can relate to but I think the
next theme that it's built should be
something totally new and different yes
I have a question yes so one of the
things that comes up when I do this talk
or even talk about CSS grid is what is
happening to the frameworks people use
the bootstrap foundation all these
things are they going to adopt CSS grid
I actually can't answer that question I
know you have it so that's why I'm
bringing it up I can't answer that
question I went and looked at the beta
version of bootstrap yesterday and it
does not have CSS grid in it they're
doubling down on flexbox as the layout
module I'm interested it's interesting
to think about where these frameworks
will go next because the frameworks are
very much rooted in this idea of using
divs and containers to create these
advanced layouts and with CSS grid a lot
of that goes away so if the frameworks
were to migrate to CSS grid they would
have to break their standard practice
and retrain all the people who use it
that might mean
that these frameworks will date themself
out of the game it also might mean that
you in this room can build a new better
framework based on CSS grid that may
out-compete these old dinosaurs just
think about that it's nice to end on a
call to action isn't it
thank you very much gone that was
fantastic
[Applause]
you